season 24 of The Bachelor has been more
dramatic than ever and we have Victoria
fuller to thank for that but the more we
get to know the contestant the more we
realize that she's not who she pretends
to be
Victoria's true colors are slowly coming
out and clearly she's not the shy and
insecure girl she wants Peter Webber to
think she is watch until the end to find
out about Victoria's secret past and how
it's coming back to haunt her in the
most despicable of ways this video
contains spoilers so you've been warned
you literally just came in here to act
like that are you kidding me the final
three have officially been chosen by
Peter Webber the bachelor of season 24
Anna Ann Madison and Victoria F are
still in the running to become engaged
to the pilot however viewers are
confused as to why the heater gave
Victoria rose after failing to meet her
parents he did visit her hometown for
that very purpose after all a heated
argument broke out between the couple
when Peter's ex-girlfriend Marisa
crashed their date to spill the tea on
Victoria's dark past warning him to be
careful
[Music]
yet somehow Peter proceeded to give
Victoria a rose choosing to send Kelsey
home despite having met her parents one
of Peters friends claims that he knows
the real reason Peter picked Victoria
over Kelsey and it may or may not have
something to do with the fantasy suites
but more on that later Peter and
Victoria have shared a special bond
since the very beginning of the season
but since the Victoria drama seems to
have been fabricated by the producers of
the show it could be that Peter chose to
give her a chance to redeem herself but
just what is Peter Webber getting
himself into
and does he truly know who Victoria
Fuller was before competing for his
heart on The Bachelor
dating history aside we know that
Victoria was born and raised in Virginia
Beach and she considers herself to be
very involved in her community at age 25
Victoria Fuller is a medical sales
representative who also works part-time
at a yoga studio
she's a social media savvy model who
loves listening to country music and
spending time with her dog Buxton on
paper Victoria's life seems to be
perfect but there's something about the
season 24 contestant that just doesn't
add up
according to Victoria she suffered
through a terrible breakup before
applying to compete on the reality
doesn't play match up to what I want she
got over the break-up by hitting the gym
and working on herself both inside and
out and now she's ready for true love
although Victoria and Peter have been
hitting it off Victoria has a dodgy past
that she hasn't been very honest about
unfortunately for her the Internet knows
everything and the cat is out of the bag
let's start with Victoria's criminal
record cause a lot of other
relationships to end in 2017 when
Victoria Fuller was 23 years old she was
arrested and charged for driving under
the influence the arrest took place on
August 25th in the early hours of the
morning according to people the news of
her arrest was brought to them by a
spokesperson for the Virginia Beach
Sheriff's Office
this spokesperson explained that
Victoria had been in their custody for a
few hours after being arrested for a DUI
after obtaining the court documents of
her arrest
Entertainment Tonight revealed that
Victoria had been found guilty and
sentenced to one year in jail however
her sentence later got suspended and
Victoria was given 24 months of
unsupervised probation instead on top of
this Victoria's driver's license was
restricted for a full year
viewers were surprised to find out about
Victoria's reckless history especially
since it didn't match with how she chose
to present herself on the show oh my god
is that appalling
early on in the season viewers knew that
Peter was smitten by Victoria but fans
were worried that Victoria was putting
on a show to seem more likeable despite
being a model who posts on the regular
Victoria had a meltdown on week 2 during
a group date fashion show to win a
$20,000 shopping spree at revolt the
contestants had to strut down the runway
however moments before taking the stage
Victoria panicked over her insecurities
and burst into tears she later told the
cameras that she felt like she was self
sabotaging however viewers couldn't help
but notice how quickly Victoria bounced
back when it was her time to shine she
went from being nervous and scared to
walking down the runway with so much
confidence it was scary but despite her
meltdown Victoria came in second place
it just didn't make any sense and fans
of the show took to the Internet to say
that they weren't buying it
viewers concluded that Victoria was
pretending to be shy and insecure to
appear more vulnerable and Rada Peter
they suspect that Victoria is a master
puppeteer who has little remorse over
her actions as long as she gets ahead I
feel like noticed speaking of getting
ahead Victoria chose to get her start in
the fashion industry by modeling for a
brand with insensitive and backward
views a decision that would come back
and haunt her in more ways than one
while on the show Victoria won a
modeling prize and was rewarded with the
opportunity to be featured on the
digital cover of Cosmopolitan however
when it came out that Victoria had
modelled clothing with the slogan white
lives matter the editor-in-chief of the
magazine refused to publish the cover
but this didn't stop Peter Webber from
defending Victoria's integrity and honor
during an interview with Yahoo's build
series Peter said that he still thought
Victoria was a good person he also asked
viewers not to be swayed by what they
saw before season 24 of The Bachelor
started filming reality Steve was
bombarded with dozens of emails from
women claiming that Victoria was
scandalous and could not be trusted
reality steve confessed that in all his
years of reporting on the show he had
never heard so many negative stories
about one single contestant most of the
emails accused Victoria of breaking up
early
chips and backstabbing her friends but
we'll cover this topic in more depth a
little later reality Steve posted an
article explaining every single email he
had received he also voiced his opinion
on the matter claiming that he thought
these accusations were legitimate
he explained that production knew about
Victoria's shady past and had even
contacted the women who were throwing
shade her way just when viewers thought
that things couldn't get any more
dramatic Peter Webber took Victoria
Fuller to a private chase rice concert
and Victoria was surprised in the worst
way possible
turns out she in the country star used
to date what's worse is that the
producers of the show knew about
Victoria's dating history and threw her
under the bus anyway during an interview
with ET chase defended his ex claiming
that she was a good person however he
also revealed that their relationship
had been just as messy as their breakup
Peter and Victoria's date started on a
high note only to come crashing down in
what would later be referred to as the
most Awkward date ever
Victoria came clean about her history
with Chase but when Peter seemed thrown
off by the situation Victoria stormed
off in tears
Peter chase and Victoria felt cheated by
the show's sneaky curveball but by the
time Peters ex-girlfriend came into the
picture that would be the least of their
worries and the singer chase the other
was in the concert yeah
after Peter went on what he thought was
a wonderful date with Victoria he was
surprised by his ex-girlfriend Marisa
pens Marisa who is also from Virginia
Beach told him to be careful stating
that he didn't know what he was on a
date with she claimed that she and
Victoria used to be friends and that she
had a reputation of breaking up
relationships and sleeping with the
husbands of her closest friends despite
having attended their weddings
Peter was taken aback by Marissa's Intel
however she explained that she was
warning him because she thought he was a
good person who didn't deserve to get
hurt by Victoria but things took an even
worse turn when Peter confronted
Victoria telling her that he had just
been approached by Marisa today I had an
accent too okay despite everything that
went down during Peter and Victoria's
hometown date The Bachelor chose to give
one of his final three roses to Victoria
this decision blew everyone away seeing
as Victoria was clearly a bad match for
him however Peters good friend Tyler
Cameron revealed why he thought Peter
was keeping Victoria around during an
interview with Strahan Sarah and Kiki
according to Tyler Peter is physically
attracted to Victoria and wants to see
where their relationship would go Tyler
stated that he thinks Peter wants what
he can have claiming that he wants to go
to the fantasy suite with her whether
this is true or not it's clear that
Peter sees something in Victoria he
would have sent her home if he didn't I
would never give you a rose if I knew
that things got even more confusing when
reality Steve reported that there had
been a showdown between Victoria and
Marissa TV shows Ace reported that
Victoria called Marissa a loser and
proceeded to lock herself in a bathroom
which she was soon as to leave according
to Marissa Victoria once threatened to
slash her tires because she was hanging
out with one of her ex-boyfriends
however Victoria seems tab lipped the
switch on Marissa accusing her of
threatening to fight her which she
claims is the reason she hid in the
bathroom in the first place all of this
drama blew up in Peters face and stopped
him from meeting Victoria's parents
during the hometown Epis
Victoria was upset and acted super short
with the pilot choosing to play the
victim card however the very next day
Victoria went to Peter's hotel to talk
things over and he chose to give her
another chance
Victoria hasn't had an easy run on the
bachelor
she's been wildly accused of treacherous
acts while having her pass dug up for
all to see but despite being painted as
a bad apple Victoria remains close with
her parents and siblings who believe
that she's a good person who is being
forged by the producers of the show but
viewers are put off by Victoria who
instead of defending herself and having
real conversations is choosing to point
the finger at the bullies who are
calling her out online
although bullying someone is never okay
there's no denying that the evidence is
stacked up against her do you think
Victoria is being her real authentic
self on The Bachelor or has the show
used her as a scapegoat for drama and
entertainment sound off in the comments
like I can't I'm so serious
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up and subscribe to the
themes for more great content we'll see
you next time
[Music]